there's a very brave decision in there
leaving the world of television where
you're successful because certainly
running for sunny and chair writing for
smothers brothers
walking away from it and saying now i'm
gonna go be a performer that's a big and
then your income gets completely shot
right i wiped
i had residuals from writing which were
diminishing right you know because
there's always diminishes and that kept
me going for a while and i remember one
time i called david brenner who was very
successful amazing and i said david
uh you know i i get paid
300
for a show
and it cost me 250 to get there he says
what do you do this was this was the
best advice i ever got that changed my
career right he said what i do
is
i
i take the door and let the club take
the bar right and i have a friend stand
there with a clicker as if people come
in come in and i had decided at at that
time to
be an opening act no longer i was in an
opening i said people do not attend or
perceive the opening act they're there
for the headliner so i decided only to
headline so i went to uh a little club
uh called uh
bubba's i think it was called in uh
coconut grove yeah and this would be the
first time i was gonna only headline and
paul's move right because who the hell
knew you no one right so my income just
really really dropped but uh that
changed my life because when i started
headlining people started paying
attention a little bit where do you
think you get the guts to do that
honestly i mean because it is i think it
takes it's inevitable i don't think it's
guts you just had to do it you had to do
it yeah and when you start headlining i
mean nobody's coming to these shows
right i mean that's very small there i'd
be playing places that seated 80 people
so you know even just the bar will sell
80 seats and what's going on in your
personal life you're living with a bunch
of guys i mean you have to like kind of
find out i'm sorry while i was uh no no
because um uh
uh early on i i
was roommates with uh gary mule deer and
a guy named michael johnson who's a
fantastic singer right and uh then when
i got the job for the smothers brothers
i had a little more money so i i lived
alone and then bob einstein and i lived
he lived above me and i lived below do
you miss those days at all when you
think back no right because there's too
much anxiety yeah there's a lot of
anxiety
it's in
i say that the last
real happiness
from
by the way i don't want this complicate
this but was when i worked at the
birdcage theater that was pure it was
pure you you were doing those little
plays yes and you could get up and do
your talent at the end all the actors
could get up and showcase themselves and
then anxiety set in which i uh endured
for you know 15 or 20 years and then i'm
completely free was there a back in the
back of your mind your glenn your father
is sitting there going um i don't think
so you don't yeah no i don't you didn't
want to prove yourself to him
well maybe there's a sub-subconscious
level of that or seeking approval
definitely i i do like uh i know about
that when you leave the world of writing
and now you're a pure stand-up comic
it's very lonely it's very focused would
you tape all your shows in some way
would you i i taped my show uh a couple
of times i was working at the boarding
house in san francisco right and i had a
bit that was a kind of a
a sleazy guy in a bar and they go hey
baby it's like i look like this yeah and
the waitress when they i start to do
this bit the waitress would come up and
give me a glass of red wine to work with
as a prop yeah and i would drink the
glass of red wine and
and one night i taped my show
and i listened back which i barely did i
listened back i could hear myself
slurring
and i said that's it i am never having a
drink before a show ever again why i
never have because that shocked you yes
and you weren't aware yeah yeah
so that's a youtuber
like three shows or two shows and you
had this one and she kept replacing it
you know you don't you're not even know
where she's replacing because the
waitress just reach up on the stage and
put the drink on this but that kind of
shows your drive like like some guys
would have said so who gives a [ __ ] i'm
playing to 20 people i'm playing at 80
people i'm playing you know it's like
wow it was important to you every show
had to be great right that was your goal
i i i guess i just
yeah you're on the line you know you
don't want to say i was lousy when you
come off and there's some point where
you're using sort of other people's
material you know comedians early on
right and then you kind of come to the
conclusion i got to do my own thing but
i don't want punchline jokes i don't
understand that what do you mean you
didn't want punchline jokes i'll explain
it you know there was i'm in college and
i'm studying philosophy and i'm
examining everything that's the premise
of studying philosophy in college is to
examine everything that's going on and i
started to
really examine comedy
and i noticed there's two kinds of
laughter
one is
when you're watching a comedian and he
says a joke and then you
laugh at it because you heard the
punchline and sometimes it's really
funny and you're laughing and other
times it's okay but you still laugh
because you're laughing on the rhythm
right and i thought
but there's another kind of laughter too
when you're home
with your friends
and you're laughing so hard and you're
crying you can't stop laughing and when
you think about it you don't know why
you're laughing right you're just
laughing and i thought what if i could
go for that
go for
trying to actually be funny where people
are really laughing and you say what are
you laughing i think i don't know
yeah right it's so absurd or something's
happening yes and i realized that these
when i was doing jokes
there there would be this laughter but
if i
just tried slightly different material
where it was just me being funny and the
audience didn't have these punch lines
to laugh at
they would pick their own place to laugh
they would they would determine what
when and what to laugh i wouldn't be
telling them telling them now once you
have that revelation well it was it
wasn't a revelation it wasn't it was a
theory it was a theory that you had to
test out yeah that i had to test out so
i i dropped all maybe i'm 21 at this
time or 20. dropped all material that i
had gotten out of joke books and i said
i have to write it all otherwise it's
not going to have a stamp of authorship
on it right and you know i was an okay
writer you know but you you'd make up
things on stage it ad-lib things and
suddenly it was in you'd come up you'd
scribble it down you think i remember
that how'd you know how to do all that
seriously there's nobody guiding you
right there's no other comedian saying
you know what although at 15 i was
shocked you would you had you would
perform in front of kiwanis clubs and
the cub scouts and you would keep a
little book and write down everything
that worked yeah how many kids at 15 are
doing that oh i've been a lot no
come on that's a peculiar thing i mean
that kind of so many kids i mean now
today you can see kids who are 12 on
youtube they're killing it yeah and i i
think that's there's much more savvy
uh information people about show
business and how to do it and what to do
you